this is a production of cornell
university
um i am going to give a lot of overview
of different things today as my bio
showed i have my hands on a ton of
different things
but all unified around earth
observations for agricultural assessment
um and so it's really just a difference
of who's doing it and at what scale and
for what purpose
um most of what i talk about today is
going to be the nasa harvest program
of which i'm a co-founder and i'm the
deputy director and
program manager and it's nasa's food
security agriculture program
but because so much of what we do is
international and connected with so many
different entities
i'll try and highlight those connections
where it's relevant
um she introduced me don't really need
to say too much here
i do use the pro pronoun she her i think
that was obvious from my bio as well
um so i'm going to start giving a little
bit of an overview of remote sensing of
agriculture
i know you guys are all agriculture
folks not sure how many of you are
working in the remote sensing domain
i'm not going to get too basic here but
i'm just kind of going to give a history
that i think is really useful for
understanding why we're in kind of a
different
period now than we have been
in the the first say 40 to 45 years of
agricultural remote sensing
um and why that matters for the type of
work that we're doing
so basically in 1972 uh
nasa launched its first earth observing
satellite which is
retrospectively known as landsat 1.
but when it was launched it was erts-1
earth resources technology satellite
and actually the very first applications
of that satellite were agricultural
assessment crop type
as uh crop type identification crop area
assessment and crop yield
um and considering how well that started
out
you know early earliest studies
introduced ndvi jim tucker who's
actually still active at nasa
today um it's kind of surprising that it
didn't kind of follow the same upward
trajectory all that time
um and so there's still kind of a lot of
potential yet to be realized but
progress has
accelerated massively and i'll talk
about why that is um
and as and i kind of always put this out
there at the beginning
one of the issues was over promising of
what remote sensing and satellite data
could do
um and i try to be very conscientious of
that and not
say that's it we can do it that's all
folks but we are seeing that
massively progress like in the sort of
digital tech startup space being like we
can do this at this accuracy blah blah
and i'm not so sure those claims are
always accurate
so at any rate the like i mentioned the
first satellites were launched in the
early 1970s
and this was something written kind of
in the mid 1970s there were some early
kind of handheld
or aerial photography type stuff doing
down in the late 60s and early 70s and
this first manual of remote sensing was
saying
monitoring agriculture from space could
be accomplished with greater than 90
crop identification accuracy yes
true true still today we can do that uh
have we been able to do that across all
cropping systems
consistently throughout time and space
no
so that's a challenge um and then that's
you know 45 plus years ago now um
and then in spite of tremendous
obstacles and variables involved
many believe that automatic systems of
tone signature
and multi-spectral imagery recognition
will eventually enable us
enable us to differentiate crops and
evaluate farm practices
on an automated basis with little to no
human intervention
again this is 1975 and that is very much
not how we're operating today
um we do have of course a lot of
very advanced farm informatics from
robots from apps and things like that
but
the human factor is a factor you're
never going to remove that from
from agricultural management at least
not anytime soon
so there was a lot of optimism you know
what
what really happened um to just kind of
summarize it quickly
great promise early on experiments um
early satellites launched in the 80s
a really bad thing in my opinion
happened which is that
nasa and usgs who kind of nasa launches
in usgs
operates landsat decided under the
reagan administration
to commercialize this public good
satellite which is effectively i mean
first of all it was not run well
and secondly it effectively killed the
ability for anybody to
develop research because of the cost of
the data
um and so that that is a huge reason
there was a pause
in in progress um in the early 2000s
uh the the director of
usgs's earth science division i can't
remember the exact role
her name was barbara ryan she pushed and
made the heavy case that
freely and openly available data is the
only way we're going to get value from
satellite data and she was right
and so in the mid 2000s um
landsat opened up its full archive and
the amount
that that was basically the precursor to
the development of for example
google earth and google maps that we all
use today
um was enabled by the liberation of
decades of data that had been collected
um and the amount of scenes downloaded
was in the kind of thousands to 100 000
per year and now it's in the
millions to hundreds of millions per
year because people are able to utilize
the data to advance the science so that
was a huge leap forward
um but there's was still you know up
until
very recently a mismatch of temporal and
spatial resolutions
of the instrument versus the promised
agricultural applications
if the only thing you can image is the
size of a football field or a soccer
field
how useful is that to a farmer how
useful is that for them making decisions
if their entire field
or significant portions of it especially
in more smallholder systems outside the
us
or you know com like very high value
crops are all blurred into a single
signal with maybe some trees and
surrounding vegetation mixed in
not very useful plus we had limits on
computation
limits on satellite overpass and on the
data acquired
um just very quickly i won't get too far
into this but this is what i talk about
when i talk about satellite overpass and
satellite data availability
um this research is getting a little bit
old now
it was actually my dissertation research
but um basically sat the landsat
missions
are we're kind of the workhorse of the
earth observation world besides
modis um up until about 2013 2014
uh 2014 when the when the european space
agency started launching their missions
but if you look at this map you know the
landsat mission was only capable of
collecting 250 scenes per day
because of how much storage there was
available on board and how often they
had to downlink the scenes
and so that resulted in some pretty
sparse coverage uh you're not getting
global
coverage on a daily basis and even so
the satellite only passed over the same
spot on earth every 16 days
so there were places in the world that
you wouldn't get a single image in a
year
there were places agricultural places in
the world where you were lucky if you
got one image
and it may be covered by clouds and so
it really wasn't a practicable
agricultural assessment tool um
so in 2014 2015 i assessed
the uh basically revisit capabilities
of a bunch of different satellite
missions and what i call
constellations or virtual constellations
um and i was looking at different
landsats that's the l7
l8 landsat 7 landsat 8 which each had a
16 day overpass
with the new east emission sentinel 2a
sentinel 2b which each had a
5-day overpass and then resource stat 2
which is an indian satellite that the
usda actually had been using for years
because of issues with landsat
and essentially um different you know if
you optimally
put multiple of them together you're
looking at like less than two days
almost everywhere globally
now we're starting to talk about
something that can actually be useful
for agricultural assessment
but then once you combine that with
cloud coverage um on the top is you know
you need your pixel or you need a scene
to be 70
clear the bottom is you need to be 95
clear so a much lower
tolerance for cloud cover there's
actually still places
all over the world where crops were very
importantly growing that you are going
to be missing your acquisitions
even with that two-day revisit frequency
between all those optimized satellites
and so basically you know even the best
case scenario
um the gaps in moderate resolution
coverage of critical agricultural areas
and times
is still and was still limiting the
utility of satellite data for
even large-scale agricultural assessment
much less kind of
sub-field um so basically
backing up a little bit i kind of
touched on the first big shift for ag
um it was around opening up data and
kind of changing the
discussion around the cost structures
for satellite data
and then um at the same time this
international research community
of uh of different people using
satellite data for a variety of purposes
not just agriculture
called geo group on earth observations
started pulling
people together from around the world to
kind of talk about what do we need
and how can this data be used and so um
geo had an agriculture group their first
meeting is
in that photo below this was before i
joined
the team but the nasa harvest director
and chief scientist so the other two
founders were a part of that meeting
early on
and i joined about two years later in
time
for the proposal to be written to the
g20
to make this agricultural monitoring
program using satellite data an official
g20 mandated program and that's called
geoglan and so i'm in ball who's in the
front the nasa harvest director and i
both serve as
program scientists for that katie
mentioned the crop monitor reports that
come out in that capacity that's where i
do the
the latin american leadership um and
then i also do
um the consulting with the space
agencies representing our thematic
community back to them
um so that was a big shift coalescing
the international community and then the
other
was like i mentioned um you know since
2015
since that research that i just showed
you know these satellites have been
launched and more sar satellites that
can see
through clouds have been launched and so
suddenly cloud cover is less
of an issue the research around
utilizing star data
for agricultural assessment is growing
rapidly and so
practical applications are more possible
than ever before and then also the
private companies big disruptors like
planet
uh maxar and airbus were you know around
for a while before that but
kind of changing paradigms in in the
cost of launching these
small satellites and the quality of
their data has gone through the roof
um and at the same time cloud computing
and machine learning techniques kind of
enable these huge volumes of data
to be processed and analyzed and
meaningful information to be extracted
um i just really briefly want to touch
on geoglam just to kind of show what the
policy relevance is
um so this is monthly wheat prices
from 1960 to 2019. you can see i
mentioned landsat 1 was launched and its
very first applications were in
agriculture
and that was really because it kind of
coincided with this period when
you know crop prices were pretty stable
and then all of a sudden we entered this
period not only of them going a first
price height going up
and that's sort of second price hike but
also just a huge increase in volatility
which is really difficult for producers
threatens food security
has impacts on all kinds of other
markets that are not just agricultural
as well
and so um after two sort of huge price
hikes
in 2008 and then in 2010 and 11 related
to drought
and related to as the g20 saw it
speculation in the market some people
knew about these droughts some people
knew about production shortfalls before
others
and bought up crops or whatever would
happen um the g20 thought well we need
transparency
and what better for transparency than
satellite data so that's really when
geoglam was established as a monitoring
entity
um our mandate has been re
re-established multiple times since that
2011 initial
establishment by the g20 um and in fact
in 2018 it was
explicitly broadened to include food
security so not just
focusing on agricultural assessments for
for calming markets
but also agricultural assessments for
combating
food insecurity um providing early
warning
of crop shortages um and kind of
strengthening
the international community's ability to
respond
to food shortages without
too proactive of an action that makes it
really difficult for the local producers
in that area to maintain their
livelihood because that's also a concern
and at the same time we're also not just
limited to that we're looking at the
sustainable development goals the sendai
framework for disaster risk reduction
paris climate accord i mean the point
here is they're big policy drivers
um that pull the international community
together to work
um on developing the national regional
and global systems for monitoring
um so anyway this is geoglam at a glance
98 98 and counting organizations
in 46 different countries um
we've we've got two regional networks
operating the one in latin america and
then the one
in asia that's explicitly focused on
rice
that um the japanese aerospace agency
aerospace and exploration agency runs um
and we have eight thematic teams
we just launched one maybe two weeks ago
that's focused on
in-situ data um so a big barrier to the
advancement of remote sensing is
we need great ground data we can't
operate remote sensing without great
ground data
um for you know for for calibration
validation and
for us to really ground our methods and
what's really happening and so
um the data that's collected is often
poor quality um we don't have standards
for how the data are collected that are
adopted across the community and so
that's now as a community what we're
trying to do
and i think it's actually going to go
pretty well this is a quick
glance at the crop monitor um we have
two global bulletins that come out
monthly soon there'll be three
this is the crop monitor for amis this
is the specific one
actually no i'm sorry this isn't this is
the combined crop monitor this is crop
monitor for amnesty and early warning
put together into a single map
amis is um the agricultural market
information system so
this is really about the reducing
volatility in the markets the early
warning one which um
sort of geographically is like central
america um
parts of parts of south and southeast
asia a lot of that is also production of
rice
for large trade and then a lot of africa
is considered a part of the crop monitor
for early warning
um that's really more for sort of the
humanitarian perspective
and so what you can see when you look at
it really quickly this is
you know policy geared we're not giving
complicated biophysical variables we're
not giving
you know really difficult comments to
parse through
with lots of kind of conditionalities
this is really aimed that
an economist or a statistician or a or a
grain trader can take a look at this and
be like okay so
i know this area is really important for
soybean and maize production and it
looks like
it's in kind of watch or poor condition
for a lot of it so
um you know i'm gonna keep an eye on
that or i'm gonna keep
you know keep that in mind when i think
about global grain production
um i'm going to skip over this because i
can tell i'm already being
kind of proposed so um this
is another thing that we do a lot i
wanted to just give a quick plug to this
regional network of geoglan which is
called agricultural monitoring in the
americas
amma and we do a lot of sort of
international
collaboration methods sharing
international research sites and this is
an example
of um a five-day workshop that we hosted
at university of maryland
with representatives from ministries of
agriculture
in argentina chile mexico and brazil
and uh at the end of it they sort of
walked away with
um 30 meter spatial resolution
crop maps and so not type of crop crop
non-crop maps for the current
year or at this point actually it was
the year before and the ability to
redeploy it in their current year
and brazil actually now operationally
utilizes this methodology to do their
area assessment so then from this they
take
uh you know they build a stratified
sample visit and they build out their
area for soybean and maize
so that's about it on geoglam that i'll
talk about and
but i wanted to kind of highlight that
global international picture
now this is really nasa's program this
is really
[Music]
focused on many of the same things that
geoglam is
because of the overlap in leadership and
the overlapping priorities as we see
them
but this one has kind of an increase in
focus on both u.s domestic agriculture
but also on sustainability um and also
which geoglam doesn't really look at
it's really a production area statistics
kind of
program um and we're really looking at
um the uh
yeah the sort of sustainability picture
and all of these things
we operate as a multi-sectoral
consortium
of over 50 organizations worldwide
and the diagram is kind of roughly
divided on the left or sort of the
public
research or public um agricultural
ministries
things like that universities on the
left and on the right we have a lot of
private sector partners
ranging from kind of informatics to
reinsurance to
grain estimators and traders to space
agencies to
consumer goods companies to input
suppliers
we basically have a lot of those
different folks record
involved in the consortium because their
needs their kind of applications are
really what drive the work that we do
um we've been around since 2017 and in
that time as i mentioned we have over 50
partners
and over 30 active funded projects and
we have a lot of other projects too that
are kind of
leveraged off of funding dollars um so
that we can kind of amplify our impact
with a relatively small budget to be
honest
and at the bottom is a picture of our
consortium from
uh mid-2019 so we've grown since then
but that was the one in-person meeting
we've had so far
um the the gist of this diagram
is that we're really aiming at harvest
to improve land use
sustainability and productivity and
agricultural systems and we're doing
that
through advancing the methods to utilize
satellite data
for crop mapping statistics yield
condition assessment and cropping
practice
mapping and assessment and i'll get into
that a little bit more later
um like i said driven by stakeholders
driven by their needs
um we're not a foundational research
project or program we are the applied
sciences program for nasa so we're
really about
bringing impact to users
in the us we have sort of six focus
areas
supporting usda's methods and so that
might be um
supporting their national agricultural
assessment or
their kind of economic research service
but it's also supporting foreign
agricultural service and their global
estimations of crop
corrupt conditions um you know
transitioning new methods over to them
and bringing new technologies to them
we work a lot our kind of priority
research area in the u.s is within
season yield in area but
also on mapping and identifying the
impact of land management practices on
agricultural sustainability and kind of
soil health and all in
watershed health and things like that
we're also really
spending a lot of time on supporting
private sector innovation
and just in general trying to improve
the productivity of u.s agriculture
while
reducing and mitigating its impact on
climate
um and then potentially you know there's
lots of discussion these days about
making agriculture climate positive
which again i'll get to in a moment
um i want to give a couple of examples
of nasa harvest impact
this is in uganda um so historically
they
basically had to you know they're kind
of operating them dark
and they were reacting to crop failure
after it happened
so people were already hungry already in
trouble
and a reaction is always more expensive
than you know
than prevention or proactive uh response
to something
and so in 2017 after working
with with us through uh dr catherine
nakalenbe who is incredible
and i encourage you to just google her
go to our website and read about her
she herself is ugandan um did her phd
at university of maryland and then
continues to work for us she's the
harvest africa
program director she has developed
and fostered personal relationships with
um ministers of agriculture all over
sub-saharan africa but in particular in
eastern africa
and the first big one not surprisingly
was down the road from her house
she's from kampala and was with the
office of the prime minister
and so she worked with them and showed
them after her field work and seeing
devastation in the caramojo region um
said like look we can see this in
satellite data you don't have to wait to
find this out
and so in 2017 they actually saw there
was no way the crops were coming back
they were not going to recover
and rather than waiting for for farmers
to continue to toil away in their fields
they were able to institute a program of
giving funds to farmers to buy
new supplies and resell their fields and
start their season over
um and kind of prevent a massive food
shortage they save money in the process
but really importantly 150 000 people
farmers who would have been kind of in a
really
bad situation were able to maintain
their livelihoods
um and not reach the point of
devastating hunger
um another example this is a kind of
covid 19 response that this is last year
the uh togolese government contacted us
and said
you know we need to help our farmers and
we don't know where they are
we don't really have a sense of where
who's cultivating where and we have no
idea how to
to to distribute this aid that we have
um to farmers so that they can
continue to cultivate food for for us as
global trade is shutting down in the
face of coba 19.
and so we worked with private sector
planet a space data provider
and within 48 hours they were acquiring
data
and providing it to us and in 10 days we
turned around with
a very accurate um crop probability
land cover classification for them to
utilize to to
put this kind of aid program into in
into effect
um another example of a public-private
partnership that we had
was uh with the with uh swiss re which
is a large
agricultural re-insurer and i think what
i mostly want to highlight here
is that we are starting to move into the
sub
sort of sub very subnational very highly
localized even sub field heterogeneity
and yields
with satellite data because we suddenly
have these capabilities
and essentially what we did here was um
utilize satellite data to develop sort
of a yield maps at both national
scale and then sub field scale to
determine where do you really have to go
in the country to develop a national
scale yield assessment how many places
do you have to visit
and how many places in a farm do you
have to do crop cuts in order to get a
reliable field
level yield estimate and we use
satellite data to train those
optimization algorithms
collected the data and then use
satellite data to kind of scale them to
national scale
um and in result you know swiss re is
ecstatic because they don't have to send
out as many loss adjusters and pay them
and there's potential fraud in the
billions of dollars
hundreds of millions of dollars every
year from lost adjusters
not entering the data correctly or
false or committing fraud essentially um
and then now they can kind of avoid that
and then for us we got
to massively improve our yield models at
multiple scales of implementation
we just announced about two weeks ago
this partnership
with cropx which is a company
that installs these within within field
little sensors on soil moisture and soil
nutrients
and uh which are critically important to
ensuring kind of the sustainability of
agriculture moving forward
and again we can utilize satellite data
to optimize where and feed do you have
to put these sensors
and then once you have the sensor
information how can you interpolate them
to provide a full field workflow
information so this is kind of where
we're pivoting toward
is this farmer-facing
effort um you know the geoglam stuff and
the precursors to harvest were all
really
government early warning trade
economists big
big large-scale pictures and aggregate
we're now starting to be able because of
the
satellite data and the methods that are
available uh we're able to really pivot
toward the farmers and i think that
that's quite important
because who controls the land farmers
that i mean it's really what it comes
down to the future of our food system is
with farmers
and so when we're looking ahead to these
big global problems
like climate change feeding 10 billion
by 2050
you know all of the decisions that are
going to reform
agricultural production are going to be
implemented by individuals
and so we need to start considering
their data needs at that scale
um and that's because climate's changing
more people are food insecure each year
we're rapidly degrading our agricultural
lands
um some estimates 30 soccer fields of
top soil per minute with if we do
nothing
done out of topsoil by 2065
which means agricultural yields gonna go
right in the bucket doesn't matter how
much
area you cultivate how many forested
areas you
cut down to create new agricultural
fields if you keep degrading it you're
going to run out
but it's worth you know you've got a lot
of these governments and corporates who
are racing to meet these challenges i
don't know how many of you follow
sort of agricultural news but just in
the 10 or
12 weeks or whatever since biden was
inaugurated
in the us there's uh an announcement of
utilizing the
commodity credit corporation's 30 or 33
billion
per year cap on aiding farmers to just
create a climate bank
and pay carbon markets but it's like
okay
how are you going to measure that how
are you going to how are you going to
what are the changes that you're going
to expect farmers to make and how are
you going to measure their impact
and so you know i think it's worth
asking what can be changed
and how can we measure it i mean so you
can obviously change land management
practices and all the nuance they're in
and you can detect the changes utilizing
satellite data to an extent
you have to integrate it with field data
and models to derive any meaning about
what's happening
below the soil but um can we use sort of
these above ground
uh biophysical variables to tell us more
about what's happening
in with respect to soil health and of
course yes
carbon sequestration which is the hot
topic of the moment right now
and just quickly to know this this came
out only a couple of days ago i think
last week
talking about um the ways in which
emissions could be reduced from the u.s
food system
and i've circled in orange the ones that
are kind of related
more or less to uh to agricultural land
use
so like refrigeration not so applicable
to what we do
but um a significant portion of
this this emissions reduction um
and this is just carbon dioxide i mean
they're not really even talking about
methane and nitrous oxide and other sort
of agricultural emissions
but a lot of this is really going to
happen through finite
implementation of changes of
agricultural land use
but at the same time i mean there really
is not consensus about
how to do that and how to do it
equitably how to do it accurately
how to do it equitably and there's a lot
of critique coming from the science
community as we've seen carbon markets
around forests
fail and in the top right this was just
a week ago or so as well
um the nature conservancy was like uh oh
we have been selling
you know for forest carbon credits on
forests that have no threat so
essentially we're giving people a
license to
pollute that's based on something that
was never a threat to begin with so
we're actually doing harm
um and that's a lot more common than i
think you than i think we realize and so
as
biden and and others in europe the green
deal they start to
unroll these plans unveil these plans i
should say
on utilizing agriculture to reduce
carbon emissions or just
to sequester carbon and they're talking
about financializing that
we've got to be pretty cautious um it's
right now it's sort of the sustainab
it's sort of the
the wild west sustainable and
regenerative actually have no real
meaning
that's that's enforceable has no real
meaning in terms of what
in terms of agreement across science
what what that includes
um and yet you know farmers are sitting
here going
they're hearing all this buzz and
they're going help you know how on earth
can we get in on this or what are we
supposed to you know what do we have to
be prepared for what do we have to
change how's this going to work
they need practical advice on to make
changes if the changes are
applicable or relevant to them national
global policies are being formed
agribusiness is aiming to meet their
kind of 20 30 commitments largely
associated with the sustainable
development goals
there are at least close to a dozen carb
independent
carbon markets in the u.s that have like
essentially no oversight whatsoever
and biden's plan is to just buy credits
from them as opposed to creating a
unified carbon bank
and again with no oversight so it's like
you know you're
they could just be putting money into
their system without actually having any
environmental impact and farmers may not
benefit and again it all comes down to
that individual land user
they implement a new practice and they
don't get paid justly for it
they're going to stop and you've wasted
an opportunity so essentially
there's a lot of need for information
and knowledge and we need to build it up
at scale quickly
um so you know just to say
there's this real focus on the
commodification
of agricultural carbon and following
very much the same trajectory as forest
carbon did
15 20 years ago um but it's being
euphemized
in my opinion by co-opting the phrase
regenerative agriculture
i am a total believer in regenerative
agriculture
but not as it's starting to be discussed
these days
um and that's because i think everybody
is focusing on regeneration
as just sequestering already emitted
carbon that really
undermines the true value of those
practices when in reality
the loss of topsoil the loss of yields
over time on farms
is a huge threat to food security a huge
threat to sort of
microclimates nearby streams being
experiencing eutrophication as a result
to excess nitrogen being poured onto the
farms because they're not able to get
the same
yields out of it there are a lot of
reasons why
we would want to implement these
regenerative quote-unquote regenerative
agricultural
practices um that have nothing to do
with the financialization of carbon
and so that's really kind of the message
i'm trying to send
to a lot of the different folks i talked
to wearing my policy hat or my nasa hat
is like look there are these practices
that we know in
certain locations certainly have lots of
benefits
including in some case carbon
sequestration but that's not the only
benefit
um you know and there's no universally
accepted definition but my
sort of working definition for
conceptualizing regenerative agriculture
is that there are locally appropriate
crop land and rangeland management
practices that aim to stop and reverse
soil erosion rebuild topsoil increase
soil organic matter improve the biota of
the soil
enhance ecosystem services and watershed
health reduce the need for chemical and
biological inputs
and contribute to increased farm
resilience in the face of climate change
and these are all really good reasons
for doing this but they lack a
quantitative basis at scale
and so here comes the nasa harvest uh
sustainable and regenerative agriculture
initiative
or sarah for short which we've recently
launched
as a public good fully transparent
multi-stakeholder pre-competitive forum
that's whole purpose is to pull together
like kind of the best of science with
the priorities of industry and policy
makers
to rapidly build that evidence base and
the measurement
uh kind of modalities to have common
yardsticks
for sustainable and regenerative
agricultural implementation
and so there's like i said there's key
knowledge gaps what practices work where
what impacts do they have in different
places and there's so many nuances
within these practices they often talk
about
cover crop as sort of a monolith there's
so much variation in that
tillage there's so much variation in how
deep you till how often you till the
type of tillage that you do
whether you do strips or the whole farm
at once the constant structural
conservation management and
what happens when you use these things
in tandem what happens when you use them
over
only every 10 years versus every five
years all of these are questions to
which we really
don't have answers but there's a lot of
potential here
and so satellites tell scalable stories
and this is this shows county level
yield but we can get down to subfield
level yield variability we've done that
now with satellites and
satellites drones and in-situ data um
this is some work from university of
illinois from caiuan in the center
looking at canopy nitrogen uptake
in in some croplands in illinois and
he's using it to essentially see at what
point do you stop
seeing a benefit of additional pounds of
nitrogen being added to a farm
reduced nitrogen usage is reduced
emissions
uh carbon to bring it to your farm
nitrous oxide from the emissions
themselves methane emissions from
fertilizer production all of those
things are huge not to mention
you don't have your nitrogen wash into
your nearby stream beds and watersheds
and kind of destroy them for
fishing and other functions and
obviously just ecosystem services
and then on the right intelligent packs
that we're seeing you know
this is in the us corn belt obviously
and i think what's really interesting
here the scale bar is yield
difference after 10 years and
the traditional understanding of tillage
impacts on yield is that tillage means
you have reduced yield
but in reality after 10 years what what
jill's research she's from stanford
showed
is that most places actually have a
yield benefit
that's an important nuance there because
if you're giving a person carbon
payments for example for tillage
adoption um eventually the carbon is
going to
saturate on that farm you're not going
to be able to sequester any further
carbon in that soil
but is there still a benefit to the
farmer are they going to be able to
continue to not till
and keep that soil that they that carbon
they did sequester in the in the soil
well if there's a yield benefit there's
a lot more likelihood that they will be
um and so lastly so what do we do
in the sierra initiative we bring
together agricultural stakeholders
from public and private sectors to
really understand their needs their
priorities
the reality is i'm sort of a pragmatist
here i'm very critical
um i don't know if that's come across of
carbon markets
very critical of uh greenwashing
very aware that it's happening i don't
really think that we're in a position to
to halt that as scientists and i also
don't really feel like that's our role
but what we can do is and i hope i've
shown this to you today is there's a lot
of other reasons why you would do these
practices
that they're looking to financialize
through carbon
and i see as again the pragmatic person
within me
well why don't we build why don't why
don't we figure out the best ways to do
this why don't we figure out
where the maximum benefits can be
experienced and the minimum
harm can happen and if some companies
get rich in the meantime
okay but we can also actually achieve
the goals
that i think they're being marketed at
this moment
and so then we're convening top
scientists and practitioners to answer
the key questions that i see as missing
where are farmers already adopting these
different management practices
what are the impacts individually and as
a sort of multivariate
situation on farm health climate
mitigation
from fields of global scales a choice
that's made in illinois
we've seen with with the expansion of
corn for biofuels having row crop
expansion
in brazil to fill that market gap what
are the
impacts both on that farm in the broader
watershed and internationally
how do these practices vary through time
space and landscape and how do their
impacts vary
that example i showed from jill is here
again i just i love this study because
it revealed something that countered an
assumption that existed in so many
biogeochemical cycling models is that
you do this practice and
there's only one possible outcome there
are a range of outcomes and that's a
really important thing for us to know
before building any incentivized system
um
and so we have this sar with the sarah
science team
that's mostly public um we do have
regrow and applied geo solutions who are
private companies
um that are a part of it and we're
trying to grow it i haven't spoken very
much
or really at all about um sort of the
more precision management
in in pest management for example and
that's how katie and i have
started to discuss some collaborations
together using blunter
using the blunt instrument of whole
field spraying doesn't have to be the
future
you could have early early disease
detection utilizing
machine learning and a mix of in-situ
and satellite methods
um to reduce the amount of spraying that
takes place on
on an agricultural piece of land um
and overall you know support soil health
and all of that
and so um
sarah is a subset of harvest like i
like i mentioned we've got that whole
big harvest program but then we have
this specific
pre-competitive forum for pulling
together the private sector and public
sector together
um and you know it was really
strategically built to operate at arm's
length from contribution so if we get
data where we get money from the private
sector
everything is uh comes in as a no
strength attached gift
which means that you know it's not up to
them
what we focus on research-wise it's up
to us and
uh we have a website built already that
will enable full accounting of dollars
and dollars out
um and the idea is hopefully as a
pre-competitive forum
we can kind of build those common
yardsticks and frame cross
industry discussion around what can and
should be incentivized and rewarded
in a way that's supportive of actual
benefit and not just
enriching the people participating in
the markets um and i just
will say you know we're seeking to grow
the sarah science team
um i'm still doing the fundraising but
we're also
open to partnerships and things like
that that can help make answer some of
these questions and make it all a
reality
um and so i'm excited to get to know you
guys at cornell
and i'm happy now to take any questions
that you might have
and i think i stayed to time so i'm
gonna just do myself patted on back
about that
you did nice job
awesome well thank you so much alyssa
for that talk so um now
like we're going to open it up to
questions um so if you guys want to send
questions to the chat i'll read them to
alyssa
um i will get started with uh one of my
own though
so just to kind of kick things off so
cornell has a rich history in a
specialty crop agriculture so basically
all these like
non-commoditized crop it's a generalized
term so i was just wondering about your
thoughts on the future of
specialty crop participation in these
initiatives the use of
earth observations for specialty crop
growers and their
diverse and specific needs yeah i mean i
think it's tied to the same trends that
we see
enabling general farm level and or sub
farm
kind of performance and analytics um
which is that you know we can
collect much better resolution
information
um which inherently has a much larger
data volume and we have sort of the
computational systems to
extract meaning from that um but
the research world in agricultural
assessment using satellite data was
certainly built around
commodity crops um but there is there
are horticultural applications
that absolutely exist and sort of higher
value crops that
require maybe less machinery to produce
in more hands-on
work um i think it's like a little bit
more of a research
domain in a sense and it's going to be
the analysis
analyses will have to be very
multi-point
you know you're going to have to
integrate within field robotic sensors
with satellite with drone with in situ
with soil samples with everything for it
to be useful
but things are becoming constantly
cheaper data and informatics
and so i think the potential is there
eventually for the costs
associated with that data collection and
analysis to be worth it to the producers
i just don't know that we're quite there
yet it's more of a research question so
it
involves a little bit of the public
funding to kind of get those use cases
off the ground if the
companies themselves are not going to
pay for it
have uh some questions here so we have a
broad question from chris smart the
director of sips here
and she asks what are the costs
what are the costs um a little bit
sorry i'm muting yeah um you said that
you know you weren't sure
if the return on investment especially
essentially for specialty crops was
there because of the cost
so my question is what are the costs i
work on specialty crops all right okay
so
um so for example um
if you you know i know in the
viticultural world when i talk to my
friends uh because that's my personal
background
you know they're really interested in
like root zone soil moisture um and
and that and the degree of precision
within sort of their
within a single row it's like a per cr
per crop per plant i should say
is really what the level at which
they're looking to fine-tune their
information
um so commercial satellite data
from planet from maxar would be the best
fit for that type of analysis because
the civilian
the publicly available free data is a
little bit too coarse
for that kind of granularity of analysis
so between sort of like the installation
of the within field networks
uh to measure some points of roots on
soil moisture
and then the satellite observations to
kind of scale it across the entire
production
um are really where the costs come in
and then there's of course
i mean so if like nasa harvest is not an
operational service provider
that's not our role is to like you know
operationally inform farmers how to
monitor stuff we would love to empower
somebody else to do that whether it's a
growers association or a private company
we're interested in the research that
kind of underpins that
um so they will have costs associated
with their operations
um you know and so we can build a
research case with nasa funding or usda
funding or whomever it may come through
um but the the the forward-looking
operationalization of it
um is going to be sort of a commercial
or a growers association that would
actually roll out the implementation of
it
thanks some more questions in the chat
um we have kenda curry raman
asks any thoughts on predicting current
and future threats to agricultural
production
by small-scale farmers in africa
um well yeah i mean yeah so like this
last year
this past year i mean again like i adore
catherine
as a person and also as a researcher her
dedication is incredible so that's why
i'm always like look
hear her words directly she's on twitter
she talks on instagram um
linkedin there's also information on our
website
um she's been heavily working on the
locust outbreak
last year um as it coincided with kova
at 19 and so you've got
kind of multiple environmental
and human natural systems like
catastrophes happening at the same time
um
and and how we respond to them
uh i mean not to be too technocratic
about a solution but early warning is
invaluable
and or in this sort of synoptic look
that something like remote sensing can
provide for early warning
is really valuable for also where do you
need to go zoom in where do you need to
send boots on the ground
where you need to send out people to
like do an in-depth assessment
um and so yeah i mean there's
between climate change um continued
geopolitical destabilization and then
things like locus
and soil degradation um those are some
of i think one of
the biggest the biggest threats for sure
absolutely um kind of along those lines
i'm going to jump around with these
questions in the chat though i
do hope to get to all of them um
marcellus acevedo
one of our faculty in triple pmb asks
for
disease and pathogen and pest
predictions what are the main
constraints you perceive as facing our
use of earth observations for such i
mean i
feel like katie probably has a better
answer to this question
but no but like in your perspective
working at this global scale
what are the challenges you see it's not
dissimilar to the horticultural or the
non-commodity crop question which is
just public investment in the
in research has been the dominant driver
of satellite observations for
agriculture until very recently
and that has been focused on large
commodity crop production
um and so you know looking at some of
the kind of finer
level disease detection has not been
necessarily the priority in a way that
you would respond to it like the locust
invasion in eastern africa for example
it wasn't like we were utilizing that
information or the design was to utilize
that information to go out and like
selectively spray for locus or something
like that
there isn't the underlying
infrastructure to implement that
it was really more like okay what's the
damage and
what are our options and so i think
similarly
um bio biologicals and chemicals have
been
readily available and inexpensive and so
it's often easier to just go out and
spray everything
even if you don't have a problem just
like preemptively spray and then
rather than go out and assess like this
is exactly what's happening because the
methods weren't necessarily there
great thanks for that answer alyssa um
so i'm going to go
back up in the chat uh so just a quick
question from adam bogdanov
he wants to know if nasa harvest is
connected to other federal agencies
invested in agriculture
such as nsf or doe yeah so
doe i'm actually actively in
communication with
the rpe program and trying to find a
modality for joint solicitations between
nasa and doe
they're working a lot on like very
intensive field sampling around
soil nutrients in particular carbon um
and
don't really have a vision for scaling
it and i think that's where remote
sensing can be very
applicable for both the kind of taking
their measurements building models and
then seeing about applicability and
feasibility
um so we're in discussions around that
um
for nsf as well um
we have had some discussions in usda
also usda has their um
sas solicitation that i think the grant
things are
due this week or something like that
sustainable agricultural systems 150
million dollars
we're in contact with meghan or who's
the program manager for that about
trying again to see
you know any of these projects having a
geospatial analysis
overlaid on top of them is going to be
beneficial
and i think for us our model is rather
than having standalone projects that are
fully integrated as nasa harvest we
would rather work with existing
expertise
and existing projects in a variety of
domains to bring geospatial and remote
sensing information where it's useful
great okay so we've got a question about
carbon markets from
christina tonito so she asked she's
worried about how the financial sector
will drive agricultural practices based
on profit
but not necessarily achieving the best
ecosystem services outcome
so what are some strategies to mitigate
funding driving practice
rather than information maybe with a i
guess a lens towards how can satellite
earth observations help with that
so i mean this is me too right so
definitely meet you i'm concerned about
that as well
and i'm concerned also about it
essentially spoiling what is i think a
very good opportunity for us to
move forward practices that have a lot
of benefit if we just bank on one
specific outcome
there are some calls like the us farmers
and ranchers
association put out um
put out like a statement or an analysis
about
kind of where things are and they were
saying well why don't we look at sort of
the practices themselves and their
broader values as opposed to tying
the financial incentives to specific
commodified outcomes um
and there's pushback for a lot of
reasons around that on the other side
um but this is i mean this is almost
like a strategy question and it's
something i grapple with a lot
and it's why i'm spending a lot of my
time these days
um i was on the phone with one of the
the president of one of the largest cpgs
in the world this morning and talking to
them about like
look like hold your horses they're
telling you that this carbon system is
ready
it is not and not in like your brand
reputation is at risk
and here's why and like let me
demonstrate a case that shows this to
you
um and so i'm trying to urge kind of a
little bit of caution and show them that
there are benefits that are available
but like you're going to cut off your
nose despite your face if you push
too strongly in the direction of
something we've already seen fail
massively
which was red plus and general carbon to
markets so
anyway so i you know it's a hard
question answer i don't have the perfect
answer strategically for how to confront
that
but i mean i i guess i'm hoping that by
getting the research out there quickly
that you know if there's a nasa stamp a
multi-research organization sample like
no this is the reality that you can't
really ignore that in a financial sector
not for too long at least yeah
so we've got time for one more question
um
so we have a question from paul who
didn't share his last name so i don't
know which paul he is
um but he thanks you for your talk as do
we all um and just want to know if you
could expand a little bit on the
countries that are
do not currently have crop monitoring um
are these related to climate conditions
small markets technologies
is it they've declined to participate um
what is the barrier to getting everybody
in on the game
this is also a really great question and
actually speaks to like a deeper part of
my background the carbon stuff is a
little bit more recent
um so like a lot of the work that i've
done over the past decade is
on institutional change and working with
organizations to incorporate earth
observations into their
data streams and they're all i can speak
for example to
my work in latin america because it's a
a large area of focus for me
and it's not you know it's not uniform
across that it's a huge
very diverse region both in terms of
culture
and uh climate and agricultural systems
but um you know central america is an
example where there
really are very limited if any
agricultural monitoring happening
um when i showed you that map of the
crop monitor that we put out there was a
report
for central america that comes from the
usaid family
warning systems network so it's not
internal reporting whereas
the reports from brazil and argentina
come from their respective ministries of
agriculture
and so we've been working i mean i've
been working with them for the half past
several years to try and build
up that capacity and it's not just
about uh like the lack of
personnel who are in the
role to do this it's also you know
some of it in central america is
honestly a cloud cover challenge
um i touched on this earlier that you
know up until very recently we were only
dealing with optical satellites which
can't see through clouds um
and this was kind of a common issue in
india as well the monsoon blocks out
like the majority of their growing
season so
agricultural assessment using standard
optical sensors
not very useful usd uh by the way nasa
and isro and india are launching a joint
star mission which can see through
clouds which has an explicit
agricultural application that's really
going to change things and so
and canada has one already europe has
one already and so we're now working on
trying to
develop the methods that utilize these
data that are applicable to the target
crops in central america
as a first cut is this even feasible and
then the second cut is that
at the same time we're engaging with
university students there
building up kind of like the next
generation workforce
and training those who are in the
ministry now and by trying to be more
like bringing awareness
of how these have been used say in
tanzania which has
which has sort of similar field sizes
different cultivation regimes different
challenges
similar biophysical characteristics that
they're dealing with
and showing like look this works we can
do this here
let's see if this works for bananas here
let's see if this works for coffee let's
see if this works for coco
let's see if this works for your rice
system things that are really important
to you guys
so it's like a kind of a companion of
research and advancing the methods
building awareness within the
institutions about the functions
and building up the workforce of people
who are in country and dedicated to kind
of answering these questions in future
generations
and then there's i mean there's always a
challenge of political turnover that's a
huge one
huge um you build up these great
relationships and ministries
there's new there's a new person elected
and unlike the us where typically they
just change the top level political
appointees
often you get the entire institution
from top to bottom is hollowed out
and so building up the constitute
continuity within that institute
my approach to it has this is where i
heavily leveraged the global program
geoglam
which is to say if that institute has
signed on to participating this global
mandate
that continues to mandate the national
system
for that organization even as personnel
change yes we have to do the work over
again but at least they
are already like well we agreed to do
this so you know
we're there from start hope that i hope
that helps it's a complicated it's an
extremely complicated and difficult and
challenging
place to work yeah it sounds like a
difficult situation but glad people like
you are working on it
right awesome so that's all the time we
have um i want to remind the students in
post docs that um
at 1 30 so for four minutes um
you have an opportunity to chat with
alyssa unfortunately there's no free
lunch because it's covered
but um so hopefully i encourage you all
to attend and just chat with her
and ask her questions if you didn't get
to do in the chat
um so but thank you so much for joining
us that was a wonderful talk so i'm just
going to give you a round of applause
just on behalf of everyone else
so thank you so much for joining us
today and i look forward to
talking about it
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu